it's been just another extraordinary day
I mean last time it was a three-hour
three hours before he was due to be
executed
this time we we all sat in a room from
quarter to twelve and watched the clock
tick towards three o'clock when the
execution was due to happen local time
and when it got those that last
half-hour was was really really
difficult and I felt almost sick I have
to say as the clock tick ran towards
three o'clock when it got beyond that we
realized well there's obviously some
sort of delay we we weren't clock
watching anymore because there was no
particular time so personally I was able
to just feel a little bit more relaxed
but we knew very little we were told
absolutely nothing we were simply told
by two prison officials that we were
allowed to leave the site we were
allowed to be escorted back to our cars
we had no idea why it was only when we
got outside that we found out that it
was a problem with one of the lethal
injection drugs not the first drug
midazolam which has been the center of
the lethal injection debate but the
third drug which is supposed to render
death
so another stay of execution let's get
some reaction Erica erica is Richard
Glossip
daughter Billie Adel is his niece
what was it like outside here for you
waiting for this news well we got the
news from the Supreme Court we were a
little discouraged and then when we got
the other news and everybody was hugging
and screaming
Bryan Stow Vijay had you I'd you have
given up hope wind when the Supreme
Court came through with their their
decision now there was always a little
bit of hope
so I had a little little twinge of
Richard inside of me saying I'm not
gonna die
what does this do to him mentally though
going through this so many times makes
us stronger makes us stronger as a
family
I reckon how is he gonna be feeling
right now everybody's very keen to hear
from him he's always gonna be calling at
some point later this evening he's
probably gonna laugh when he gets on his
bone because we always tell them on the
last phone call we'll talk to you
tomorrow and it keeps being that way so
I'm just I can't wait to talk to him
me either cuz I told him last night last
thing I said is I love you and I'll talk
to you tomorrow
and I'm gonna talk to him today 37 days
what does that give the lawyers in terms
of a time to gather more evidence that
they can presumably try another legal
challenge I'm just gonna say they're
awesome they've been working really
really hard and we'll just see what they
can do faith in them I do we are
gathered here and there's lots of the
supporters who've been here as as well
the media are largely still inside still
trying to you know work out what this
this is what this really means I mean
one of the extraordinary things is I
feel as if I've been the paradoxes that
I've been at the center of the story in
the sense that I've been inside and do
to witness the execution but because
we're in a complete information vacuum
there we are told absolutely no
information whatsoever
you could learn more information as a
teenager on Twitter than we have had
inside but coming out to the news that
the execution has again being postponed
it means that there is now a delay until
November and Richard Glossip lives to
fight another day
it wasn't the way that he would have
wanted it necessarily and his lawyers
would have wanted their to prefer to a
legal victory but they'll take anything
they can at this stage and and run with
it and try and get more evidence which
they think could help prove that in
their words he is not guilty of this
murder